toyota s'est senti mentalement c'est dur
mentalement bois je suis très bien
j'espère berra c'est con parce que
j'avais peut-être un dos pourquoi je
peux te donne un indice
elle porte une robe rouge cette deuxième
analyse elles portent mieux la robe
rouge cadre roumanoff même si on aime
bien troisième à dix elle n'a pas de
grand mère comme le petit chaperon rouge
c'est votre sylviane et non à aider que
quand tu ne m'as fait le démarque par
non mais c'est vrai ça veut dire qu'elle
aussi dit oui alors les dit à l'ats
alors j'ai trouvé très beau bien
[Applaudissements]
quant à une mocheté dans la leur garde
et elle était comme ça tu cicta m'a fait
regarder l'émission et latin l'avion de
chasse mon frère c'est aussi la solution
où tu dis que tu aurais tu fais nord
voilà je suis mac et autres yahoo
thudinie combo tu te lèves et tu dis
rien là bas
non mais c'est moi et a pas 36 solutions
d'or il ya deux réactions moi je rougis
donc franchement c'est l'enfer pour moi
ce moment là la voilà et puis et puis ma
meuf à l'émission cieux de danse
paraguay alors on va pas perdre ma télé
c'est à dire moi alors qu elles soient
pas le vôtre et catherine catherine a
arrêté ma fille
[Applaudissements]
baptisé d'accord à catherine et bah
écoute avant de te coucher ou en bois